today on campaign check the
conservatives promise to get brexit done
if Boris Johnson wins a majority on
Thursday
he says he'll ask Parliament to approve
the withdrawal agreement before
Christmas and on January the 31st the UK
will leave the EU so in the narrowest
sense brexit will be done but we will
not be done with brexit having agreed to
leave the UK will then be in a
transition period in which EU rules
apply still a pie until December 2020
that gives the Prime Minister just 11
months to negotiate and ratify a trade
deal with the EU in fact the timetable
is even shorter because if the UK wanted
to extend the transition a decision has
to be made at the start of July
now the PM insists he won't ask for an
extension but he said that about
extending EU membership beyond October
the 31st this year so will he do it
again recently you trade negotiations
suggest a deal will take much longer
deals with Ukraine and South Korea took
9 years a deal with Canada considered
the model for the UK took 7 and deals
with Japan and Singapore took 5 years
each all of which suggests 11 months is
heroic ly ambitious and arguably
unrealistic the UK and the EU both want
a free trade agreement but a deal will
be hugely complex with numerous issues
to resolve in exchange for zero tariffs
to help manufacturing the EU will want
trade offs for access to its markets the
UK wants to move away from EU regulation
but divergence as it's known is likely
to lead to more checks and more red tape
for example if the UK changed standards
for food to help a separate deal with
the u.s. the EU might want to prevent
access scores of other issues like
access to UK fishing waters the NHS
security service industries and energy
could all be in play and even if all of
that is resolved the deal will still
have to be ratified by EU Parliament's
and here at Westminster all of this
matters because the EU accounts for 49
percent of UK trade and if there's no
deal and no transition the current EU UK
relationship would fall away with
dramatic consequences for the economy
Boris Johnson's campaign has been built
on delivering
exit but victory this week would only be
the start to finish the job on his terms
he'll have to complete a trade deal in
record time it's not impossible if both
sides agree to compromise but most trade
experts believe the Prime Minister will
again have to contemplate no deal or
break another promise and seek an
extension